you coward you
scum I will SP in your face out if I
could if I could see you face to face
Israel First Palestinian second you are
a monic first and a scum second and then
a third you're an
Israeli just imagine the people back in
the day when they would have to travel
certain distances for months or even
years what is one thing that they would
carry with them the Quran why because
they did not have it on their mobile
devices or their gadgets brothers and
sisters imagine you have a app the Quran
app which not only shows you how much
rewards you get but reminds you to read
the Quran gives you reminders download
the Quran app now and let it testify for
you on that you read it wherever you was
all right guys so this is Luna and we're
going to see you know how obedian he is
when he's given a biscuit as you can see
Lun sit sit well sit sit good
no okay so that's a female dog and as
you can see we came to his owner and
asked for permission he gave us a
biscuit you can see how much he has
loyalty to his owner his master that
looks after him so much show that as a
random person who had a biscuit he even
listened to me when I said sit down
that's the Loyalty of a dog but not
every person is loyal as a dog and some
dogs are better than some human beings
like nass this is what this individual I
don't think he's a Muslim maaf he's
probably he's probably not even a Muslim
as far as I know last time he said this
person was a NE yeah hypocrisy here's
what he has to say this coward this look
look look what he said personal thoughts
for the longest time I struggled with my
identity you're a coward you never had
an identity you are a coward like
Malcolm X said if you don't stand for
nothing you fall for anything you are an
absolute coward yeah a Palestinian c kid
kid born into Israel like what the f
okay many of my friends refuse to this
day to say the word Israel and call
themselves palestin and call themselves
Palestines only why the hell should they
accept it you think everyone's a sell
like you you coward huh bro I wish I
come across you in life not I'm going to
do anything to you I would love to see
you face to face you coward I'm not even
Palestinian but since I was 12 that did
not make sense to me so I decided to mix
the two and become a Palestinian Israeli
I thought this term reflected who I was
Palestinian first Israeli second just
wait till the end guys yeah okay but
after recent events I started to think
and think and think and then my thoughts
turned to anger Subhan Allah was you
anger angry for the sake of your
brothers and sisters who have been blown
into pieces who have been oppressed for
the past 75 years you coward of course
not I realized that if Israel were to be
invaded like that again we would not be
safe to a terrorist invading Israel all
citizens are targets look at how we
cause those individuals who some deem as
Freedom Fighters yeah as terrorists but
Israel and what has been doing and
killing Massacre men women children you
coward you
scum I will SP in your face that if I
could if I could see you face to face 67
kids got killed massacred did you say a
single word did you call Israel
terrorist State never you coward and it
reminds me of couple of under
individuals like Farris yes and the rest
who are quiet who would never condemn
Israel as well anyways will not be safe
again uh to terrorist invading Israel
all citizens are Target so look at the
compassion he has yes of course innocent
people no problem but to occupying
forces military in the individuals yes
there's a conflict that's going on 900
Israelis died so far more than 40 of
them are Arabs killed by other Arabs and
even two taii people died too and I do
not want to live under a Palestinian
government you coward you you don't deem
yourself Palestinian which means only I
have one home even if I am not Jewish
which is Israel there you go bro this is
this is literally a house Palestinian
yes if you get what I'm saying that's
where all my family lived that's where I
grew up and that's the country I want to
see continue to exist so I can exist you
cannot make this stuff up W this guy is
should I tell you something if you lose
my brother brother I would disown you
brother you are the biggest scum double
standard bum
sh you are Palestine should exist too as
an independent state and I hope to see
the country Thrive and become less
extreme you can't make this stuff up bro
bro you canot this guy is the definition
of a coconut the definition to become
less extreme so they are extreme for
wanting the lands that was stolen back
and they are fighting to defend their
self and that makes them extreme and not
a single word of calling that state
terrorism no and I hope to see the
country th and become less extreme and
more prosperous I love Palestine I am
and I have invested in palestin you are
a coward BR you are a coward go invest
in your soul it's not my home so from
today onwards he goes I am I view myself
as an Israeli Palestinian Israel First
Palestinian second you are a maafi first
and a scum second and then third you're
are an Israeli so it's very clear guys
that sub these people these sellouts
this coward w w if you see this
individual just look at his face and say
shame on you shame on you you coward you
sold yourself for a few dams of money
you remind me in the Quran where Allah
talks about pharaoh and ham those who
sold their own people very interestingly
the B is they sold their own people you
remind me of them and Allah subhana tala
swallowed him and all his might and his
wealth and everything that you are
putting first be before your Palestinian
brothers and sisters who are going
through that may Allah subhana wa tala I
ask Allah subh to destroy your wealth I
ask Allah subhah wa ta'ala to make you
suffer how your brothers are suffering
may Allah subh put no Barak in your life
may he make you suffer like a dog and
inshallah you turn to Islam and fix your
ways inshallah and repent for what
you've done you flipping utter coward I
hope to God I see you face to face one
day inshallah so I can say these words
to your face you are an absolute coward
no backbone shame on you you're a little
weasel that's what I have to say to you
may Allah deal with people like you
brothers and sisters support your
Palestinian brothers and sisters
wherever they are the link is in the
description box below inah and by the
way pring to the dog we're allowed to
Pat dogs and yes it's didck my finger
which I would have to watch as the
prophet described the